it seems to me that everything here is
wrong every every level of everything
for example that they waited till night
time to announce the decision and
knowing that the people were going to be
out there they already gave the kids in
school off on Monday and Tuesday
shouldn't wouldn't it be better to have
the kids in school so that they don't
have to be out on the streets I mean it
just seems like every level of where the
system could fail it has failed so far
and until I'm proven wrong I say the
half those fires are 13 fires I want to
say about half of them or insurance
fires and the other half were started by
the cops even though you have no
evidence but you're willing to well I
don't have any evidence otherwise I mean
it would be consistent that the criminal
element in that community are the cops
the prosecutor and the whole st. Louis
cop community are racists and criminal
right it's every time they come on TV
they're revealing themselves to be
criminals and corrupt transparently I'm
not reading into what they're doing so I
it would be consistent that the
murdering cops and the other prosecutors
who cover for the murdering cops would
also be arsonist people go you can't say
that it's consistent it's it's not a big
crime to be an arsonist as a murderer do
you think perhaps the cops are actually
causing fires because then it makes the
protesters list all the false flag
operation and yes they did it in Mexico
they just did it with the protesters in
Mexico they burned they started a
building on fire and said and blame so
yes at no doubt by the way they're
shooting tear gas which is illegal
internationally you can't use tear gas
and people in war you can't use tear gas
except we use it on our own citizens
those [ __ ] pricks and use it on our
own goddamn citizens chemical weapons
left and right and they're shooting tear
gas how do I know they didn't shoot a
tear gas canister into a tire shop and
start a fire that way I bet they did in
fact so I'm so I'm with you on like ten
percent of the that fire seemed I'm not
going off the deep end with you but the
fire seemed odd that they were bursting
all over the place just places were
sudden and then they were like that was
one car on fire we all saw the one car
on fire then there was two cars on the
show the safest
parthalan get a chance to look the same
a lot and then they wouldn't put it out
until all the cars caught on fire then
they brought in the fire department
right okay they waited for all the go up
bend you on a couch you a little bit of
which any side near the top set fires
although the first time that died you
said that yesterday will on the young
turks and I thought it sounded dots but
amusing and then uh and then but now
you're like firing teargas in the tire
shop that was the first I was like all
right okay maybe but I don't think the
cops would start fires to blame it on
the crowd on purpose is that really
crazy I'd i think that the mean the bill
consistent with their criminal behavior
i got well that's no their criminal
behavior is not necessary it doesn't
they don't need their criminal behavior
to be that insidious they get to do it
in the open like their criminal behavior
is uh we could discharge our weapon
where we see fit and then we stand by
our guys and we don't properly
investigate the case and then the
prosecutor presents a nonsense case to
the grand jury unlike he's ever done
before and we don't get a guy undated
like it's no big deal with hot set fires
now was the do they have a vested
interest in sort of it looking like
mayhem you know chris hayes on MSNBC
kept pointing out there that many people
here what but theoretically you would
see some someone at some point would see
someone set a fire these fires were not
said in parts of the town where nobody
was so theoretically some people
protesters saw if a cop was doing it I
mean I guess he'd be undercover but I
don't get too hung up on I'm saying a
cop could easily tell a guy that that's
what they do all the time they make them
turn and give them information so you go
hey I will prosecute you or you know
we're gonna charge you for murder unless
you go start this fire and they did
three months to plan this I got that's a
pretty here's the thing if that happened
that is an unbelievable story and a
great story and no I mean it's a tour
unbelievable it's a fantastic story a
story that journalists would be like but
concept this is this is the greatest or
I've ever written two pretty big risk to
be paying informants off to set fires
accounting that those informants are not
going to talk about it later but not to
publicly go on camera and reveal that
you're a corrupt because that's what
that prosecutor did and he said I'm not
going to prosecute this guy in fact I'm
going to act as a defense attorney for
the cop who murdered a black unarmed
there is a five feet away doesn't have
to answer to anybody for that I mean
what work we both think this guy's a
corrupt and should have been should
never been on the cases father of course
was a police officer uh killed in the
line of duty by a black suspect with a
gun but by a black killer with a gun so
and what's the prosecutors what is his
record on prosecuting cops who shoot on
our men why it's pretty solid he's a
he's a he's over 50 45 he's over 50 he's
a crook um all right well I I no no I
would basically say that you know it
claims like that you need some evidence
behind it but yes he wouldn't but yes
getting the evidence is hard because
they're probably good at it so I'm sorta
with you so just last thing on this what
do you think at this point what do you
think the protesters want what do they
gain at this point by now you know
blocking roads and all and the whatever
looting is going on all that what what
is their end game at this point or is it
just to keep it guess my question is
when is it so we just had we just get to
have a completely corrupt police we
completely corrupt a attorney county
attorney who's not going to prosecute
murdering cops Jesus so when is the
federal government step in and do
something you know they's the one is he
nationalized the National Guard instead
of letting the [ __ ] governor who's
also corrupt who didn't replace this guy
and I'm not saying that he's a criminal
I'm saying he's Craven politician who
wouldn't do the right thing the right
thing was to replace this prosecutor and
he didn't do it for political reasons
when do they nationalize the National
Guard and say you're no longer a police
department don't answer that question
bring us home what is the government do
now to just expect a little more from a
chief executive named Nixon right okay
uh the uh I don't know the federal
government's investigation is continuing
their there's two investigations
essentially that they're looking at two
options both Ferguson Police Department
in general but and then immediacy what
do they do in this justice in these next
couple days where it's still going on
there now we're seeing it spread what do
you think they can do to kind of
desperate point another prosecutor the
governor can do whatever he was he could
see they can they still can prosecute
this rap but that's the stuff that's
weeks away or months away or whatever
you know that's not happening tomorrow
he's not suddenly replacing him tomorrow
and reconvening well you know I I don't
know I don't know what's gonna happen I
don't know whether the the pressure
would be so intense that it might cause
something like that to happen everyone
seems legal experts seem to say
that's incredibly unlikely yeah
incredibly unlikely it's not
unprecedented of the century because you
have to show intent and not just intent
to kill but you have to show intent to
deprive someone of life liberty the
pursuit of happiness as opposed to what
the obvious case for every cop who kill
somebody in the line of duty as I felt
threatened for my life with the clan
members in 1964 in in Philadelphia
Mississippi the famous mississippi
burning them the movie that those cops
were prosecuted under civil rights
violations because they were in the
client right and it made it may be made
in line it made it it made it a leisure
but ever since that law was written in
reconstruction in like 1870 and it
didn't have the intent part the intent
part got added that intent has been has
been has been interpreted now to show
that you have to gain they have to
directly show it's hard to show the
Darren Wilson is a racist so that's why
that's unlikely but if not it's it's not
impossible i read a piece in slate today
where the headline was the feds should
charge Darren Wilson uh with some civil
rights murder uh but they probably can't
and here's why yeah all right well I
think if we've proven anything it's that
this case isn't going anywhere and
obviously we will keep talking about it